Lizzy McGuire's back I can't take it
what made you want to come back no I
think the conversation finally got
exciting for me when she's she could be
30 she has like her life she's been with
the same dude for two years so she is
coupled up we don't know how long that's
gonna laugh just saying what we have
something to show you now 2002 Lizzie
McGuire set visit with Entertainment
Tonight I'm such a normal kid I don't
really even like to think about it cuz I
mean like when I'm done with work I go
home and I hang with my friends and I do
my homework and I take out the trash and
stuff like that so oh my god who is that
girl
what is it doc what does adult Hillary
do after work now like hustle to get my
kids cook a few meals I was just talking
to a mom friend of mine I was like it's
just a constant rotation of food no one
eats at the same time no one needs the
same things I like instantly take off
any sort of evidence that I have a job
outside of like being mom all right now
to my favorite show younger I love this
show so we're gonna hurt Lizzie's
feelings you haven't even seen it yet I
know you're right Lizzie's great
Lizzie's so wonderful I'm wondering
what's happening in the next season have
you seen a script yet honestly this show
for me has gotten better and better
every season I don't know how the
writers have accomplished that with like
the storyline in the beginning so like I
don't want to I don't you starting
filming in March have you stolen any of
the clothes I had a pair of the shoes on
there do they work with all my long
pants let's move on I have something
very special for you we have our very
first interview with you in 1998 this is
on the set of Casper meets Wendy
I think that it's not hard at all I mean
I love doing it the people on the set
here are are very nice and wonderful
people who share very gracious to your
dreams yeah very Handmaid's Tale so and
they still what would you tell about
Hillary oh my god I guess I would be
like you're not gonna believe this like
Ryan you're not gonna believe what's
gonna happen I kind of makes me want to
cry it makes me emotional yeah you're
funny you've done a lot it just had like
the days go by so fast the years have
gone by so fast I have done a lot and
when I see like that little girl I still
obviously have her inside somewhere you
know so okay some very big news today in
addition to your 900 other jobs you are
officially the chief brand officer for
not one but two new lines Vita and have
the little camper alright so why do you
side these with the lines who wanted to
use your name to partner with PETA is
amazing and I've switched over obviously
to using all-natural products in bem
care happy little camper is plant-based
just becoming a mom are you just like
fufufu there's just so much crap that
you don't even know how to pronounce and
these diapers and it's really nice that
a company like this is taking all the
guesswork out you're not having to worry
about it now that everyone's hearing you
talk about it where can everyone get all
this goodies so many stores across the
country carry happy little campers and
Vita but you can go to their website to
find a store near you and you can
[Music]